I mean you obviously went to college
here
um
have you noticed like the turn in like
the city just kind of like things
getting a little crazier out here I mean
I think it's getting publicized a lot
like like there's always been [ __ ]
happening in La obviously but
um it feels like just like
I mean LA and other cities it just goes
to show that this is the reason why
women is running you know
rap and hip-hop because there's just so
much violence and disrespecting the male
music you got to think like remember
when what was that like 16 17 number one
like YG Tyga Chris was out it was like
fun Big Sean it was fun party T Fly yeah
but it was like fun party music it
wasn't like I'm gonna do this to you and
this this you know right so it's like I
feel like we had to raise the vibration
with the music and get back to having a
good time yeah I feel like um
there's definitely a lack of
empathy and love yeah that's real
for real that's real yeah I think some
people are doing it but like you said I
think too that Instagram [ __ ] is like
crazy like I just saw NBA young boy No
Cap going back and forth all [ __ ] day
today on Instagram and I'm just like
Jesus Christ NBA boys I think it just
sounded like a 300 million dollar deal
or something like the [ __ ] off Instagram
who cares with no cap saying like I
don't know that's another humor there